alright my how the world has changed
thousands of Google employees just
signed a letter chastising their company
for working with the Pentagon to improve
the precision of drones so only bad guys
get killed in war not civilians
it could change war forever reducing
mass death yet these employees think
that's evil
go figure so think about this how does a
company like Google thrive well it helps
to exist in a country with the world's
greatest defenses which enables freedom
to thrive it also helps that over a
half-century ago American companies made
up of young men and women helped us win
some world wars without that would be
speaking German
instead of using Google during World War
two US industries produced more than
three access countries combined that's
300,000 planes
100,000 tanks and plug your ears 115
million guns all of this from the home
front so how's the home front now
well these childlike Google heads think
they can live forever in a silicon
bubble immune to the real world's risks
and responsibilities seemingly unaware
of the sacrifices grandparents and
great-grandparents made to enable the
comfy Google lifestyle as terrorists
refined their own technology and planned
the next 9/11 these kids at Google think
their expertise should only be used for
getting directions to a Thai restaurant
thank God they weren't around in the
1940s so Kimberly this drones are going
to be used to target bad guys so you
have less collateral damage how can you
be against that well right it just
doesn't make sense but you know when you
look in terms of the political ideology
of like Eric Schmidt
I mean running Google was at Hillary
Clinton campaign events were in Politico
about all of the above anyway they go
through this whole background checking
etc it's pretty much a little bit of a
lockstep overwrite there's a progressive
ideal so they think that it's you know
the right idea to be on the right side
of it to say oh we're against war were
against this and have this kind of
positioning but they really don't
understand what they're protesting
against if you're protesting against the
Pentagon or Department of Defense or
anything like that being involved this
is what's actually helping you be safe
in terms of even cyber security so why
are they
I would they be opposed to this it's
just it's just not very well thought out
yeah you know Kennedy I could see this
in a world without terror and toxic
existential ideologies that wanted to
destroy the earth we are in a different
kind of war it's not a war that is on a
battlefield it's a war that's kind of
around and waiting the up for the
opportunity should these people be
arrested that work at Google that's a
little authoritarian yes it is did you
be arrested Kennedy absent for other
things the night is young but I will say
this there there is merit to being
anti-war and I understand that and I
understand the desire and the thrust to
use technology for positive means for
bringing people out of poverty for
educating people that's all well and
good and that's fine I don't have a
problem with that and I also agree with
them that the marriage of big government
with big technology is really scary
because it good way you mean no I mean
if war and and surveillance are combined
essentially were powerless that's why
the Second Amendment is is really really
important so people can defend
themselves but if you know the drones
though you could defend yourself with
drones get a drone yes does everyone get
an armed drone yes people with my and
the question is always not how can this
be used what is the intention because
the intention is almost always good it's
how can it be misused how can this power
be misused and you know argument with
every technology though Kennedy you can
say that with every and and then I I
pose this question to them what
government functions are acceptable mmm
excellent question
Jason perhaps you could answer that yeah
well look I think don't mention anything
about soccer
these Googlers are showing a degree of
immaturity and you know what if you look
at the National Guard the men and women
who serve our nation on both sides of
the aisle they don't have a specific
political ideology and then you look at
some snotty kid at at Google who's
trying to say yeah but our technology is
better than that we shouldn't allow you
to have this I just believe in peace
through strength the reason the United
States of America is the greatest
country on the face of the planet is
because we've had hard people do
difficult things in that there is a
price to freedom right and
they don't want to participate in that
they don't want to use their expertise
to make us and keep us the greatest
country on the planet that is so wrong
one well I don't understand this what
the young people and I don't know what
they're young they could be Eric Schmidt
States wrong yes okay so the people at
Google are saying you can't outsource
moral responsibility for your technology
so what Kennedy said is right what
happens when people start using this for
evil purposes and then you say oh gee
this is what's going on with Facebook
and allowing people to come in and they
create these psycho graphs which is now
becoming more and more of an issue on
our own voters on us as citizens and
influence our elections now in this case
guess what they have a model that says
don't be evil typic Hritik right and I
think this is in this age I'm really
surprised that you Greg because you have
been hard on artificial intelligence and
saying that artificial intelligence can
be used to hurt us as human beings and
so now you're saying oh no just let all
artificial and tell all technology fall
into the hands of people whose job it is
to kill people no what I'm saying is
that if this helps make weaponry more
precise in the battlefield
you will save innocent lives civilians
we won't have things like Dresden where
you have to bomb entire cities instead
you have a drone that hangs out in front
of somebody's window waiting for that
person to leave that terrorists leave
and that person because that just goes
apps it that's what they're trying to do
like a bug zap like a bug zapper under
President Obama how much he misused
drone and speaking of a Republican or
Democratic president if Hillary Clinton
were president right now with these
thousands of Google employees mmm
manufacture the same letter good point
they were they're upset they signed a
huge layer a thousands of them so I
think it's 3,000 I'm signing this letter
they're upset too about for example
getting involved with the conservative
CPAC and all those typing and it's just
so it's a political thing